it is the ET extraterrestrial reunion at
our 40-year anniversary of the film
coming out Henry Thomas Robert
McNaughton and D Wallace
I mean
Henry
I I don't think any of this would have
worked you know without you
were the perfect Elliot well thanks
but I think I mean when I watch it now I
can't believe how funny you are and how
cute you were this little scene stealer
yeah you come on
you don't even have to open your mouth
you just kind of come on screen and the
focus just goes
who I think we all were yes that's what
he did with all of us now Robert the
first time you saw E.T was that surreal
you did you get a glimpse of him like
when you weren't supposed to like did
you accidentally find him how what how
what is the rumor there well I think
they on purpose I think Stephen wanted
me to see him the actual working model
for the first time when I actually see
him in the film the scenes on the bike
were filmed first so the only thing I
saw was sort of this fake looking dummy
in a in a basket right wrapped up in my
heart sank I thought you know this is
the actual this is what's going to be ET
you know it looks so fake it was like
rubbery and it looked they wrapped it up
in a blanket so it wouldn't be obvious
but still we had to do stunts and stuff
so when I saw it was a scene which is
brilliantly choreographed with you
screaming
E.T running through with his arms up and
you know and me backing up and the
shelves falling down which they didn't
tell me was going to happen the shelves
were a complete surprise
Steven had the prop guys on the other
side of the shelves pull the pins so
that that was that got part of the
reaction you know now I believe I
believe tea was real
[Applause]
like I really really
loved him in such a profound way is it
like true that what what would happen
because I would go and take lunch to
them well yeah
well you would the thing I remember the
first thing I remember is that this we
were on stage and it was quite cold in
the stage on the stage and
uh you asked the Wardrobe lady if you
could have a scarf for et's neck because
he's getting a cold so you wrapped the
scarf around his neck but Dee has a
great story because well you would go we
found you over there just talking a way
to eat
and so we let Steven know and so Stephen
from that time on appointed to guys to
keep E.T alive so whenever you came over
to talk to him he could react to you
[Applause]
I had a very wild imagination and
when I came onto the set I was like this
is my family Stephen can be my dad you
can be like my mom and you are my
brothers you guys were like so good to
me I was like so annoying was I such a
beautiful bad because you're saying how
great we were and sometimes we weren't
that great yeah
I'm sorry see my kids fighting or
something they're like oh God I'm like
oh it's siblings wait don't you know
what siblings are like you always wanted
to be in our gang and it was me and
Henry and Matt demerit and you were
always trying to get in you were always
trying to like
and we weren't you know fully grown-ups
yeah so we would sometimes ignore you
which is the worst thing that we could
have done it's what it's what siblings
do to each other but you've helped me
understand it was it was real it was
just the best experience in the world
[Music]